okay going back to the 70s for this
movie review this is kind of a weird one
yeah boy and his dog 1975 with Don
Johnson which I didn't actually realize
I had actually I don't think I ever saw
this movie I saw a mannequin I didn't
know it was this old I didn't either and
actually it's funny because I didn't
really realize it but watching and I was
like wow it's just like Mad Max then I
was like oh this came out before and
actually George Miller has said that
this was kind of a big influence on Mad
Max on the look of it and everything
like that
yeah I'd also have to say probably
fallout the fallout video game series
basically this they took a lot from this
yeah this is almost kind of like a side
mission to fallout a lot of the themes
tone of it the way the shacks look and
the kind of state of humanity in the
wasteland and then an underground
civilization going on that's trying to
have kind of like a utopian version of
the 1950s yeah and it's it's very much
like fallout yeah it's it's pretty much
exactly the same thing and I think even
the Wikipedia page for the movie even
points that out like I said that the
premise of this is very weird it's
actually based on a Harlan Ellison
novella and it's kind of like it's
post-apocalyptic but it's also a black
comedy yeah it's weird it's action but
not in the way that Mad Max was right
Mad Max there's a lot of vehicle fights
and you know and not not in the boy in
his dog
boy in his dogs all about like on foot
survival yeah there was a series of
books post-apocalyptic books I used to
read now as a kid in the 80s called the
traveler series and the traveler series
is a lot like this also I'm sure that
whoever wrote that series it's been a
long time since I've read it whoever
wrote that series was inspired by this
one by boys dog you know it's basically
a society full of a post-apocalyptic
society full of savage men that
basically just kind of hunt down and
rape and kill women there aren't very
many women left well yeah there wouldn't
be yeah yeah and that's the way the
traveler book series was and that's the
way this for this movie is and they
don't explain it it doesn't make any
sense
but hey things don't make sense
sometimes yeah in a way like
I kind of I had heard of this movie I
had a vague idea that it was like
post-apocalyptic but I didn't really
know what it was about exactly so it was
kind of enlightening to just like watch
it without any expectations yeah and
this is kind of one of those things and
I think the 70s was like a really good
time for this particularly for sci-fi
you could do some weird [ __ ] like weird
premises and not really explain it and
people were like okay during that time
they had you know magazines Illustrated
magazines or comic books you know yeah
eerie and creepy yeah and heavy metal
yeah and you could tell that this story
is right from that generation yeah of
writing yeah I used to like those old
comic books it write pretty cool and
like I said I should note too that
Harlan Ellison who was notoriously
cantankerous but he actually quite liked
this adaptation of his work he said it
was probably the most faithful
adaptation of anything of his that that
had ever been put on screen other than
he he didn't think it was quite
misanthropic enough because he's you
know like I said he was kind of a crabby
old fart right brilliant writer though I
have to say but the thing I liked about
this like I said was that it didn't
really explain anything they're not
really the only explanation you got the
year was 2024 yeah you know there had
obviously been some kind of nuclear
apocalypse my seventies rage 70s it was
World War four is what they called it
and it had wiped most of the people out
and then there was like a struggle for
survival that was pretty much the only
explanation there was you're then
introduced to the character of Vic who
was played by a very young Don Johnson
he's supposed to be 18 yeah I forgot
which Don Johnson looked like because I
can remember him from the television
series was a Miami Vice yeah and he was
much younger than this he's very young
wanting something probably he's doing an
18 year old and he can just by that he
does yeah I know how good-looking he was
he was a good-looking young guy yeah
some reason kind of reminds me of Rod
Stewart in a way he's better look like
that yeah yeah kind of like a Rod
Stewart but quite quite a cool character
in the movie named Vic and he's got this
dog that he can talk to this dog but
only he can hear the dogs response he
talks to the dog telepathically yeah and
it is some kind of a
police dog runs across this girl and the
girl asked him so how come I can't hear
him you can hear him I can't hear him
and he just goes in the end really
doesn't give an explanation yes
basically you said well because we think
alike it's some kind of a genetically
engineered dog or some kind of a
cybernetic police dog oh sorry
what I think they didn't really
explicitly say yeah Vick couldn't
explain it he didn't have them yet cab
you Larry because this was he had been
raised apparently his parents were both
dead I'm yeah and he had been raised
after the war so he didn't really know
anything about it so he's kind of
portrayed as sort of a simpleton yeah um
and the dog whose name is blood and
coincidentally that's the same dog that
was on the Brady Bunch
okay that same dog actor yeah delegate
and it's a very good actor that dog
right and he's very cute he's a very
cute little dog the dog is actually the
most intelligent character by far in the
he's he's very erudite the way he talks
yeah he has very scholarly he has a kind
of like an exceptional human level of
intelligence and education and very
stylish [ __ ] every yeah he knows
everything like he knows every theory
and so he's trying to teach the human
character yeah like about history and is
trying to he's like quizzing him on it
right girls are kind of busting his
balls all the time yeah you know hey
only thinking about girls and that yeah
he's very base character right Vic is
he's a barbarian
he's a total barbarian pretty much
everybody in this movie is barber yeah
for the dog and even those people even
those people were bad are barbarians but
they have like a veneer of inanity yeah
like this nineteen fifties country
condiment except like a weird grotesque
parody of it yeah yeah it's cool foot
which like I said you'll kind of see if
it is because we were kind of debating
because I'm not sure how widely seen
this movie is like I said I had heard of
it and it kind of roughly knew about it
but I had never got around to seeing it
yeah and it's kind of a cult classic
yeah and it's in a weird situation
because it's in the public domain you
can buy and sell this thing you know
nobody owns it and I bought a blu-ray
edition of this which is must be a
bootleg I can't figure out who made it I
got it for four dollars and twenty and
thirty three
since delivered off the ebay from an
individual and it came new in a wrapper
it had markings on it as if it was made
by a company it doesn't have any title
screen you put you put the blu-ray in
and it goes directly to the movie yeah
it doesn't like have any I don't even
think it has any extras no no extras
there's no title that goes right to it
there's I don't even
you can't even choose the chapters right
nothing like that it just plays now it's
not blu-ray quality maybe it's not a
remastered copy it's gotten no it's
definitely not yeah it's not shitty but
it's not great yeah it still looks at a
1970s movie it's a lot better than you'd
see on VHS and maybe it the colors might
be a little bit better than DVD but
there's something about the shittiness
of the way that this movie looks that
kind of adds to its creepiness yeah I
agree it's like you're seeing something
from the apocalypse yeah this movie kind
of reminds me of like I said a lot of
movies that came out in the early to mid
70s like in the sci-fi realm that had
these kind of bizarre premises almost
like not quite late Logan's run but kind
of like Soylent Green or you know even
like what was that other one that we did
about the with Harvey Keitel Saturn 3 or
whatever that war is it's similar kind
of thing but this is much funnier yeah
and like I said it's almost kind of like
it I don't know it's not like funny ha
ha but it's like kind of like a real
like a nasty wicked black humor type but
it's very understated yeah it's not
goofy no not at all it's just showing
you like a bizarre possible future
things are happening as if that if it's
normal and it's not normal and it's
never explained why this is now the new
normal
like why are a bunch of little children
on leashes pulling a car chassis through
the desert with the guy dressed up like
a king eating peaches it's never
explained well in the thing to you
O'Malley explained this is what I found
interesting about the telepathic dog
angle yeah now the whole beginning of
the movie which is mostly just Vic and
the dog like talking to each other
trying to find a woman oh because I
forgot to mention that not only is the
dog telepathic he can also he has a
little BP like a radar that goes off
whenever there's a
in the air yeah he's got entry Scott
wait he's got him programmed he's got it
set up to where he finds women right and
basically Vic just hunts down these
women rapes him and then kills them I
guess well there is no him doing that
but it shows other guys doing it shows
other guys doing that and him not
necessarily being upset about it he was
just upset about that one time that she
was dead by the time he got there no
because they had cut her up oh and he
was like oh what a waste
yeah cuz I could have used that yeah it
could have had sex with her after she
was like right it was so it was like
that it was more like you messed it up
for other people right yes so like I
said this is and this is like the new
normal now it's right here it's like
it's not commented upon yeah what I was
saying about so so yeah the dog can also
sense women in the area and it's like a
little BP thing that goes off but the
thing about it was that at the beginning
of the movie like I said cuz I didn't
really know you know what it was about
or where it was going which I kind of
like you know when I see a movie to not
know where it's going yeah yeah when I
can't spoil this this is just a teaser
but you can watch this movie for free so
we don't want to spoil it you know you
can see they actually I think you can
see it on YouTube for free probably like
I said it's in the public days so it's
not really good to know where you're
going with this movie you just have to
kind of roll with it what I was saying
was that at the beginning of the movie
when it was mostly just Vic and the dog
and I was just thinking oh well either
he's just imagining that the dog is
talking or that's the only dog but then
later on they imply that other people
know that dogs can telepathically talk
or some of the dogs or that some of the
dogs can yeah but again this is not
explained and also when he when he goes
down to the underground bunker yeah they
don't explain I mean you can kind of see
where they're coming for their man
technology is more advanced than it
appears on the surface right you can't
we can't spoil everything but not all
things are as they appear yeah good and
but well what I was more talking about
was why they didn't explain why they
tried to put society back together in
some weird circus like parody of like a
Norman Rockwell sort of man kind of it
was like it's almost like down homey
Midwestern America except weird and
kind of a total this kind of a
totalitarian 1950s idyllic version of
country life yeah but I think it may
have been kinda like we were talking
about earlier with Logan's run like a
time capsule
yeah something where you could keep a
breeding population in stasis until the
surface was habitable it may have been
right yeah I don't think that was the
end goal what you saw I think it was
just they were just holding that was
like the transaction transition period
yeah I was kind of in an emergency
posture until the surface had become
habitable which it was habitable but not
by much it didn't look like you could
grow anything yeah it's like a big
desert it was just like a big desert
with like people with yeah shitty
vehicles and they were driving around
looking for and they had tried to kind
of put in like you said this is kind of
where the fallout yeah it looks more
like fallout fallout but you can see how
some people have attempted to like put
together like they had like a little
ramshackle movie theater well yeah all
they had was like 30 stag films yeah and
that's what it would fall out like yeah
so it's it's a lot like whole thing is
like fall out the structures are like
fall out on the surface and that's where
fall out of the guys that made fall out
I think really got a lot of the ideas
yeah of course you know those memes kind
of went through Mad Max type films too
yeah because like I said this was a big
influence on George Miller on the Mad
Max movies they're not interesting a
thing about this was that the director
of it was lq jones and he didn't direct
a lot of movies he was actually mostly
an actor he was in a lot of westerns
like a lot of sam peckinpah movies and
stuff and so it was kind of interesting
to see a movie with this strange of a
premise made by someone who didn't
normally direct movies it was just kind
of this is probably the weirdest sci-fi
movie from the 70s that I've seen and
I've seen a lot of weird ones just
because like I said it was so and I'm
not sure I want to put it it was so much
itself it's just kind of come on and
just presented it and Danny for me the
tone of the movie I mean some people
might look at go man some old shity kind
of 1970s no there's more to it than that
the way it's kind of cobbled together is
it's kinda like a movie that was made
after the apocalypse comics yeah it's
almost kind of like meta yeah it's like
you're actually watching yeah and it was
made in the apocalypse right so which I
wonder if he did that on purpose because
it does kind of come across like yeah
because some of the edits in the audio
and stuff is this like what kind of
equipment was this used you know but
yeah it's something that they found
during the apocalypse right make a movie
but you're right that might have been it
I think it's more than deliberate
because it I had the tone that I was in
the apocalypse watching a
post-apocalyptic there's somebody else
somebody made in the epochal and we're
showing and we show it to you this is
this is actually now and we're sharing
it at the shitty movie this shitty move
right after 30 SEC's that's that's kind
of how I think it was supposed to be and
if it was that's kind of a brilliant
conceit that was done on purpose that's
how I am and it wasn't just done just
because they didn't have the money or
whatever but well they didn't have the
money so they said well we're gonna go
full of pot let's go full apocalypse and
make it like yeah I kind of like that
and now I kind of might think that's
what it felt like because 74 you can
make a much cleaner movie than that but
yeah much better than that so it's
almost kind of like they went out of the
way out of their way to make that look
kind of rough that's true and they said
well it doesn't matter doesn't matter
the the oh the overall effect was that's
how I'm gonna look at this movie yeah
I'm gonna give him credit now I've heard
I think Shout Factory has done like a
really nice array edition of a restored
version and I've heard I haven't seen it
but I've heard that it's very nice and
it was very crisp looking and stoked but
you know like you said there was almost
something kind of cool about seeing it
yeah we saw it that was kind of like
it's coming butl and you look at Martin
Martin looks like a homemade snuff flick
yeah you're like this happened in the
next neighborhood over somebody just
videotaped this [ __ ] and this has that
feel - yeah I think the best thing about
this movie is the dog and the voiceover
the dog because like I said the dog
sounds really he's very intelligent and
he's really snarky
yeah and he's always like you said he's
always busting Vic's balls all the times
for being a dumbass and you're like only
having one thing on his butt jerking off
and for ya
yeah he's always like getting all over
his face and picking on him and stuff
but despite that and despite how
horrible a character Vick is or how
horrible a person he still has some
decency down in there and the dog is
almost kind of like his conscience like
is this is a weird thing to say but the
dog is the only redeeming character in
theatre I interpret it was is that the
new normal was pretty damn horrible yeah
he's just part of the new normal he was
like a nice guy for them at that time
where everyone was horrible but the dog
was the only I mean he was the only good
character yeah yeah and like I said I
know the kind of the cool thing about it
is that he was a remnant from the old
world right golly and like the only
thing about and I think the reason that
you sympathized with Vick even when he
did horrible things was because him and
the dog really did seem to have this
bonding this you know male buddy type a
relationship and there was actually some
actually love between them yeah so I
think that kind of redeemed him somewhat
and like I said the dog almost seemed
kind of like his conscience yeah in a
way he was always trying to keep his ass
out of trouble and you know trying to
keep him from doing overtly stupid
things and John uh Don Johnson does a
good job with Vick cuz Vick yeah that
comes off as kind of like a Johnny Reb
kind of a Old West survivor
yeah it has a Western feels are very
kind steep south you know I mean Wild
West kinda time you know it's like
something from the 1800s kind of like a
Billy the Kid character it's not yeah
post-apocalyptic Billy the Kid right and
like I said you know the guy that
directed this had been he was an actor
in a lot of westerns and stuff so this
definitely does have a western you ever
to it I haven't read the original Harlan
Ellison novella if anybody has let me
know I've read some of his other stuff
but I haven't read this one so I'm not
sure how much of that Western element
was present in the book yeah and I have
to say - I'm not going to give away the
ending but the end of this movie like
the last couple of minutes oh yeah it's
awesome it's almost kind of like the
punchline of the only long involved joke
so you really have to pay attention to
watch the whole thing in the end and
it's just like yeah we can't spoil yeah
but it's worth watching and you know if
you like fallout you'd love this movie
it's kind of like a fall
outside mission and if you like bird
eared seventies
yes IFI movies and Mad Max and bad max
that type of thing this will probably be
right up your alley if you haven't seen
it like I said it's more of a black
comedy right but if you're in the right
mood and if you kind of dig that kind of
thing I think you'll kind of dig if you
haven't seen it it's just pretty weird
like I said it's the weirdest yeah one
of the weirdest 70s I can watch it for
free on YouTube I don't know how good
the transfer is it's probably shitty or
you can buy the bootleg blu-ray somebody
selling them on eBay for about I think
that for 433 delivered yeah can't really
go wrong the I didn't see the scream
factory remastered Edition that's
probably worth a lot yeah back shelf
countries well scream factory yeah it's
the same company that's true they do a
really good job they usually do and they
usually are good about getting a lot of
extras and stuff and I actually heard
there were some good extras on the shop
factor version that said like interviews
with Harlan Ellison or goes with the
director and stuff that might be worth
it so it might actually because Harlan
Ellison is always entertaining to listen
to is he's such a Crabby yes he's so
wonderfully crabby he's awesome but yeah
but and the fact that he liked this
movie is kind of a big deal because like
I said he did he hardly liked any
adaptations of his work because he was
just really can't anchor yeah I think
it's too this movie is too old to do any
deep analyses on because it would give
spoilers and it sold a lot I haven't
seen it I think I think just doing a
regular teasers slash retrospective
VISTA wait like I said we kind of have a
hard time with this because sometimes I
want to go like into the themes of the
movies and stuff like that you'll ruin
and then I'm like well it came out in
1975 but then I think well maybe a lot
of people haven't seen it and then a lot
of people that saw it may passed away by
now yeah people were in their 30s when
they saw it back in the seventies yeah
that might that might be the case too so
it's like I know how you can say oh we
have to have a you know X amount of year
limit on spoilers then you can't be
spoilers anymore but you know they get
to be so old I had not seen this movie
you know I hadn't seen it since I was a
kid right I thought it was from the 80s
I didn't realize it was from night I
didn't realize it was as old as I didn't
realize that this was pre Mad Max
actually yeah so that kind of surprised
me what I found
I was like holy [ __ ] 19:7 Utley the
source material for Mad Max and and
fallout oh yeah definitely
oh yeah that's definitely where this
came from yeah but yeah so check it out
if you like weird 70 sci-fi and if you
haven't seen it I certainly hadn't I
don't know how I missed it but I did but
I really liked it it's totally bizarre
and if you liked the show remember to
Like share subscribe on all your social
media and share with all your friends
and relatives and whoever you might know
if you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page
which is patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or you can go to our blog which
is 13 o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation that would be much
appreciated also remember to tune in to
our regular episodes that come out every
Tuesday and our movie reviews which come
out every Friday and until next time bye